c'est vrai que vous avez une image de
dilettante un peu de mecs qui bossent
pas qu'antoine de caunes a annoncé cet
été vouloir faire une émission intitulée
antoine s'en fiche une émission dans
laquelle il aurait rien su de ses
invités tout le monde lui a fait
remarquer que tu me dis à vous
mais je le revendique aussi n'ont pas et
ne rien faire mais de ne pas avoir comme
vous des fiches parce que pour montrer à
la télévision vous travaillez il faut
montrer quelque chose si vous bavarder
avec jean luc mélenchon si vous le
faites sans fil ça apparaît comme une
conversation c'est vrai m tandis que si
vous regardez melanson dans les yeux a
évolué dit jean-luc vous regardez la
fiche le le 9 septembre le 10 octobre
1992 donc vous la lisez bien la fiche
vous avez voté oui au traité de
maastricht et en 2005 j'avais voté
contre et là vous êtes
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
1h10 tube abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux